here at home the CCSD Board of Trustees
scheduled to vote on a reopening plan
that is scheduled for tomorrow night so
Brian that plan would actually mix
online learning within class session
something superintendent dr. Jarrah says
was required by the state
8:00 news now reporter sasha Loftus
spoke to parents teachers and students
just ahead of that decision Sasha Denis
and Brian some say they're good with the
plan while others believe it's set up to
fail as we get closer to that final
decision those I spoke with tonight just
want CCSD leaders to understand where
they're coming from when it comes to
ccsd's reopening plan and pulling my son
out of CSD I feel like it's reactions
certainly vary I think that the plan
that they have is ridiculous and I don't
think I'm gonna even follow through with
it but regardless of stance parents
teachers and students are eager to make
their voices heard and not really
realize all these teachers at high risk
the proposal which trustees will vote on
Thursday allows families to choose
between two blended instruction models
or stay with distance learning the plan
that they provided us is is great it
gives the parents the options to choose
well some are good with it
others say it puts teachers at risk they
need to be there the first week and see
the reality of what they're asking us to
do many also worry their special needs
students won't get the help they deserve
I'm angry because I don't understand why
these children or my son is getting you
know thrown under the bus but no matter
what happens those involved urge
district leaders to understand the
importance their final decision holds we
only have one shot to do this now again
the Board of Trustees is set to vote on
the reopening plan during its regular
meeting tomorrow will of course bring
you the very latest on eight news now we
also have a look at the entire proposal
on our website 8 News now.com